Speaker 1: This is a really interesting piece
in the New York in the Los Angeles Times,
rather, by Doyle McManus called Joe Biden
has become the anti Reagan and his speech
to Congress will make that clear.
Now, this was, of course, written before last
night's speech, but it was really confirmed
by the address Joe Biden gave to a joint session
of Congress last night.
Joe Biden and his biodynamics, his economic
ideas, as they're being called, are truly
based on the opposite principles of Reaganomics.
Reaganomics, boiled down, was supply side
economics, sometimes called trickle down.
The belief that cutting government spending
is good for the economy.
Cutting taxes, income taxes and capital gains
taxes, particularly on the rich, is good for
the economy.
Reducing regulation on business is good for
Tightening the money supply is good for the
economy.
And also a Reaganomics includes the idea that
giving people help will make them lazy.
Joe Biden and biodynamics, as they've been
dubbed, are the exact opposite of Reaganomics.
Now, to be really clear, this doesn't have
to mean that Biden is ultra left or as left
as Bernie or whatever, but his views are truly
the opposite of Reaganomics.
Reaganomics is supply side economics.
Joe Biden is demand-side stimulate the economy
with spending and by increasing demand, Reaganomics
is about cutting government spending.
They almost think you can cut your way to
prosperity.
Joe Biden believes you increase government
spending on the right things.
And that's good for the economy.
It creates jobs.
It injects money into small business.
Reaganomics is cutting income taxes and capital
gains, especially for the rich.
But Biden nomics is about increasing them
on the people most able to pay.
Since we know that the hoarding of money by
those people is not economically stimulative
compared to well thought out, properly targeted
government programs, Reaganomics wants to
reduce regulation on business and let it rip.
Let them do whatever the hell they want.
Joe Biden recognizes we must regulate in order
to prevent the further destruction of our
environment, which long term would be terrible
for the world and of course, terrible for
the American economy.
Reaganomics wants to cut the money supply.
Often they want higher federal funds rates.
Biodynamics is about increasing the money
supply through thoughtful stimulus spending.
While Reaganomics would have you believe that
if you give people help, it makes them lazy.
The Biden idea is that if you give people
help, you make it so that they're not constantly
treading water, trying to avoid drowning.
They will become more innovative.
They will be more predisposed to become more
productive members of society.
Notice that nothing about the Biden view is
remotely socialist.
It's almost religious Keynesianism.
It's a different form of capitalism.
Some people don't like that.
Some people didn't like the FDR New Deal because
they were well to the left.
Socialist wouldn't really have liked the New
Deal because it did a lot to sort of cement
industry in American the American economy.
It's similar with Biden.
There's nothing socialist about this.
And as Doyle McManus writes in the L.A. Times
piece, Reagan made people hate government
and then debate.
Whether government should do anything at all
because the default is government is bad,
Joe Biden's approach is government doing things
can be popular if they are done correctly,
if they are the right things to begin with.
Vaccine distribution, covid stimulus are too
great starting point because they're so popular,
even with many Republicans, that could then
build goodwill towards the proposals like
what Joe Biden outlined at last night's speech.
This is very different than what we saw after
Reagan, which was the demonization of government,
the constant drumbeat about cut programs,
cut social programs, and we could be entering
a new era.
Now, I don't say that hyperbolically.
It's just, you know, there are eras.
Eventually, eras change.
We could be shifting to government being seen
as a tool to help people if the tool is used
correctly.
Even Republicans, we have to admit, under
Trump sort of drifted away from as much demonization
of government.
You still saw it, of course, but they've drifted
away from it a little bit.
And part of it is that while the Republican
Party is busy fighting this culture war, they've
completely abandoned.
Oh, sorry, I punched my mike.
They've completely abandoned policy.
If the options are government doing stuff
under Biden or nothing happens either way.
While Republicans just talk about the culture
war and Dr. Seuss government, doing things
starts to look quite good.
And that's part of why we see a strong support
among Republicans comparatively for Joe Biden
on vaccination, as well as Joe Biden's one
point nine dollars billion covid stimulus.
So we are going to follow this very closely.
But the antithesis of Reaganomics appears
to be what Joe Biden is rolling out as economic
policy.
Things have suddenly taken a very ugly turn
for Donald Trump's, I guess former do we know
former lawyer Rudy Giuliani, a Rudy Giuliani's
apartment and office have been raided by federal
investigators as part of an investigation
into possible crimes committed by Rudy Giuliani.
This is an absolute blockbuster situation
for a number of reasons.
But understand that Rudy is being investigated
for possible crimes committed while working
as the personal lawyer for a sitting president
of the United States.
There is a ton we don't yet know about what's
going on, but we are slowly learning it.
The New York Times has a very good report.
What we know is that search warrants were
executed at both Rudy's home and office.
Investigators seized what are being reported
as multiple laptops and mobile phones.
This took place yesterday morning at 6:00
a.m.
That's relevant if you come in at 6:00 a.m.
at both the home and office simultaneously.
I asked on Twitter, actually, is the execution
of the Rudy search warrant at 6:00 a.m. relevant?
If you do it that way, is it a sign you're
worried he'll try to destroy evidence if you
come in calmly or schedule it?
And indeed, former FBI agent Aharon GAPA responded
to me that, quote, Most searches happen early
in the morning.
Primarily, there is simply a greater likelihood
that the subject will be home.
As you note, it will also be less likely to
be observed with time to destroy evidence,
etc.
And in the case of dangerous individuals,
it's safer for agents.
Now, of course, Rudy's lawyer and Rudy himself
are saying this is outrageous.
This is not necessary, certainly not.
At 6:00 a.m., he's being treated like a criminal.
This is a 76 year old man, Rudy Giuliani's
lawyer, Robert Costello.
Remember, Magga, means making attorneys get
attorneys.
Trump's lawyers lawyer, Robert Costello, put
out a statement saying, quote, What they did
today was legal thuggery.
Why would anyone do this to anyone?
Why would you do this to anyone, let alone
someone who was the associate attorney general,
United States attorney, the mayor of New York
City and the personal lawyer to the 44th president
of the United States that will be evaluated
if feds acted inappropriately with the raid
or doing it at 6:00 a.m. or whatever, it'll
be determined.
But in the meantime, a real practical question
is, do we really think evidence is still around?
And what I mean is these guys have had more
than a year to destroy it all, haven't they
almost certainly done it or at least tried.
It is true that the FBI has a way of recovering
things you think you've deleted.
But the point is Rudy knows he's been at least
a possible target for a while.
One other takeaway.
They are starting to claim on the right that
this is a Abidin directed political hit job.
We have no reason to believe that that's the
case, but we actually have reason to believe
it's not.
And The New York Times reported that investigators
were looking for a search warrant to do this
and get Rudy's mobile devices and such while
Trump was still president.
But political appointees of Donald Trump to
the Justice Department blocked it.
So this actually predates Joe Biden.
They were investigating this during Trump
and they weren't able to do the search warrant
because Trump appointees blocked it.
So it is that obstruction, not Joe Biden,
which has led to this.
Taking place in April rather than when Donald
Trump was still president of the United States,
truly stunning stuff.
How far will this go as a problem for Rudy?
We don't know, but it's not looking very good.
Later on in the show, we'll hear from Rudy's
son and his reaction to this.
And we'll have continued coverage of this
on The David Pakman Show Instagram page.
Make sure you were following us there at David
Pakman show.
Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman.